senior White House and political
correspondent Ed O'Keefe joins us now
for more on the upcoming election Ed
let's what's not a presidential election
this year but they're both out the
current president and the former one
both active as well as President Obama
um president Trump saying a bunch of
things here in the past couple days how
is all this impacting the race right now
well look they're all out essentially
trying to help members of their party
maybe just give them a little lift here
at the end and you can see sort of in
where they're going where the help was
needed he started former president Trump
did in Iowa because Senator Grassley was
sort of caught in a close and
anticipated race they think they fixed
that he's going to be in Pennsylvania
along with presidents Biden and Obama
today and then he'll go to Florida to
hold a rally with Marco Rubio but not
Ron DeSantis who might run against him
in 2024 a bit of a snub there and then
ended in Ohio a race for the Senate that
they're you know keeping an eye on and
could be closer than they like President
Biden look where he's been New Mexico
California Illinois why because again
Democratic and then in New York he's
going he's going just north of here it
doesn't happen but the reason is because
there are Democrats in these tight races
and a presidential visit can give them a
little bit of a lift and one of the
messages I think it's been the biggest
message for Democrats not just President
Biden I even heard Terry Washington
talking about this so actors getting in
on this is that democracy is at stake
yeah not just talking about other issues
but democracy is at stake is that
message getting through and having an
impact well no on Tuesday but Democrats
seem to think that if you remind people
of what happened in 2021 uh you know
right there before the inauguration in
Washington and the fact that there are
so many Republicans out there who
continue to talk about the big lie that
could potentially motivate people you
just kind of reminded hey remember what
happened forget about the economy forget
about the economy for a second this is
an issue that you should be thinking
about because a lot of Republicans are
campaigning on it a lot of eyes on
Georgia what are the other big races out
there George of course in its Senate
race uh we have a big set of races in
Nevada Arizona Pennsylvania of course
which is why all the presidents are
there this weekend balance of the house
as well these are the 10 that we'll be
watching on Tuesday night Republicans on
the right of course want to turn some of
those blue ones red Democrats hope they
can at least take Pennsylvania and turn
it blue if they get Ohio too that would
be a really big night for them yeah how
tight is that race in Georgia uh it's
still Tick-Tock tight and it keeps it's
the one that could be yeah and that's
part of why we you know the rule there
is you got to get 50 plus one neither of
them are pulling above 50 percent if
they don't get it on uh this election
night they'll have a runoff in early
December is going to be a long
nights
one of the numbers we just saw flash up
there and if we can put it up again
election deniers about 300 of them or so
across the country these are 308 and and
the way CBS news tracks this is this is
people who either say you know the 2020
election was stolen or they voted
against certifying Electoral College
results in Congress or they've signed on
to lawsuits challenging the results in
some states and look at that 20-36
Senate candidates 20 of their 36
gubernatorial candidates more than 200
of the house candidates it shows you
it's widespread and it's a popular if
misguided belief among many Republicans
more than half of Republican candidates
yeah absolutely all right Ed
get some sleep right now you're not
getting any next week exactly we
appreciate it thank you and happy
birthday thank you sir oh very nice